now when you have the world's Reserve
currency the rest of the world wants to
save and they save in that currency and
that leads the country who has the
world's Reserve currency to borrow it
gives them what's called the exorbitant
privilege of being able to borrow and
print the world's currency boy that's a
good thing to have and then what they do
of course is as Prosperity continues and
asset prices go up like stocks go up and
everything does really well
um it encourages more borrowing and
spending and betting on prosperity and
that begins to have a rise in levels of
indebtedness so you see debt levels
rising and the third thing it does is it
creates a greater wealth and values gaps
to become greater naturally
um well the wealth that's built up is
distributed uh unevenly and those who
make a lot of money then begin to have a
larger wealth Gap and um that's
um that creates also an opportunity Gap
and if we're lucky enough to have the
money we can educate our children well
and so on that gives them an unfair
Advantage as in relationship to others
and so this wealth Gap
increases at the same time as levels of
indebtedness increase and then of course
what happens is the competition
increases the competition increases
because when you win and you have the
other Germany or Japan or other
countries uh destroyed after the war and
there are no other competitors then it's
a dominant position but over with time
others learn and begin to build up like
China particularly has increased its per
capita income and its competitiveness
and so China is a competitor with the
United States but all through that time
it was like the British were competitors
with the Dodge and so on so we see that
pattern happen over and over as that
power Gap Narrows uh then conflicts
about how things should go increase and
internally there is a conflict over
wealth and wealth gaps and then there's
a higher level of indebtedness which
makes for a worse set of circumstances
and that combination of circumstances
now leads to more conflict and more
problems so traditionally you see that
if you have the a lot of levels of debt
um the classic way that you see this is
what does the government do and doesn't
have enough money it's not like they go
into the coffers the coffers are empty
they have no gold they have not that
money so where do they get the money
they have to take the money from
somebody else that's either through
taxes or what they do more people get
angry when they're taking it away and
there's a big fight over it so what they
usually do is they print money because
and through the Roman times back in
Roman times they had gold coins they put
less gold in the coins they put other
medals in the coins and inevitably they
print money when they want to spend more
and that of course course produces the
inflation it devalues the value of money
and when and you lose buying power and
when that happens with the same time
there's there's a large wealth Gap
um an opportunity Gap that produces a
lot of internal conflict of the sort
that we're seeing now